Hey, next up, you know the incredible Molly Ringwald
just had a birthday!
(audience applauds)
And of course, who could forget her iconic character
in "Sixteen Candles?"
She played a high school kid
whose entire family forgot her birthday, remember?
Well, People reports that this year,
Molly's real life mom made the same mistake
that her parents made in the movie.
And Molly posted a text exchange.
It was almost four PM on her birthday,
and then she wrote her mom,
"That's it, you don't have anything else to say to me?"
Oh my God, that's literally what Samantha says
in the movie!
Right?
And her mom texted back,
"Oh, I didn't realize it was the 18th.
"Happy birthday, I haven't got your present
"in the mail yet.
"Will do very soon."
(audience laughs)
And you know, she's turned 54 this year.
Do you think at 54 years,
does mom get a pass at this point?
You know what's cool?
What?
I don't know if this matters or not,
but my daughters asked me to make a wish
on my birthday this year.
Really?
And I said, "Well, do you remember
"the end scene of 'Sixteen Candles'
"where Jake Ryan asks Samantha,
"'Go ahead, Samantha, make a wish,'
"and she says 'It already came true'?"
Yes.
I said "That's how I feel."
Aww.
I don't think I have anything to wish for.
(audience applauds)
Oooh!
Awww.
But I found one anyway and made it.
(audience laughs)
All right, next up, we've got a relationship expert
who's going viral on TikTok
for a simple little piece of advice.
The New York Post reports that Rachel DeAlto
has over a million views for her video
where she says,
"One thing that we must normalize in relationships
"is boredom."
She says all relationships get boring at times.
Boring moments, boring nights,
boring conversations.
And that's okay.
It doesn't mean the relationship is bad or over.
It's the natural ebb and flow.
Rossy, thoughts.
Yeah, okay, yeah, no.
(audience laughs)
I don't like...
I don't like the word "boring" here.
Because I think the semantics are very important, right?
If you could replace the word boring with comfortable.
Right?
We had a nice comfortable dinner.
We had a comfortable conversation.
Then that's fine.
But if you are bored with your partner,
something is up.
I don't think that's great.
Am I wrong here? No?
Right?
I know maybe the word she chose
may not be perfect.
But the lack of drama.
Or anxiety.
Or nerves.
Oh my gosh, doesn't that mean something?
And I don't know.
That's a good point, yeah.
My joke about like,
the rollercoaster of life applies to relationships too.
You're gonna have ecstatic moments,
exciting moments, kind of lulls and quiets,
and not so exciting.
It just seems like that's the way life goes.
Like it's this.
Thank God it's not that,
'cause you don't want that.
That's true.
That's dead.
And I would like
comfortable, as you say.
(audience applauds)
Agreed. Agreed.
Agreed, love that.
All right, next up, we're gonna talk the latest in fashion.
And the New York Times Style Magazine reports,
this spring, the hemlines are rising with the temperature,
and the miniskirt is making a comeback.
Look!
(audience laughs)
These teeny tiny skirts are everywhere,
as we eat our pasta.
Check out-
(audience laughs)
Nicole Kidman is on the cover
of Vanity Fair's Hollywood issue
in a little teeny high skirt.
Now Drew.
(audience laughs)
Are you gonna be rocking a miniskirt?
No.
(audience laughs)
Certainly a miniskirt and a crop top
seem to be on the menu too.
We'll be right back.
(upbeat music)